hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and a massive
Quirk Evolution just happened right
before our eyes and this is only the
beginning the Raging fight against all
for one just gave us some big hints
about how the final battle between
shigaraki and Deku might end and by the
time this war is over Deku May no longer
be what we think of as human horikoshi
is still keeping a secret about how all
for one and one for all really work and
this secret is about to be revealed so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our mha videos and
you want us to keep them going leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it really helps
us out with that YouTube algorithm and
if you're one of the over 50 of people
who watch our videos but still haven't
taken the time to subscribe do me a big
favor and subscribe right now
subscribing on YouTube is completely
free but it helps me out a lot finally
this video will of course obtain mha
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter we saw multiple
important developments including aizawa
and present Mike being saved from
falling to their deaths by kurogiri but
then also being transported to an
unknown location this means that while
both of them are likely safe erasing
shiraki's Quirk using izawa's Quirk is
no longer a possibility and although the
floating UA building is no longer in
danger of crashing to the ground and
everyone on board is safe for the time
being the final showdown between Deku
and full power shigaraki who now has
full use of all his quirks is only just
beginning the focus then switched over
to gunga where all for one confirmed
that he needs to physically reach
shigaraki in order to force his
rebellious new vessel to obey him he
will do this by placing all for one's
Quirk Factor inside of shigaraki's body
and this will then somehow destroy
shigaraki's ability to fight back
against all for one's control but even
before all for one confirmed this Hawks
had a feeling that the heroes had to do
their best to keep all for one from
leaving gunga and getting to shigaraki
so these new Revelations only further
emphasized that Hawks was right the
chapter ended with the injured and
exhausted Heroes at gunga getting some
much-needed reinforcements courtesy of
the hero students from shiketsuhai Kami
seiji and inasa oh and something else
was revealed in the last chapter that
might seem small but I actually think
it's very important we learned that
civilians from the UA shelters were
supposed to be evacuated by the shikitsu
high students but they never arrived at
the scheduled meeting point something
went wrong with the evacuation pay
attention to this piece of information
because it will come up in future
chapters the latest chapter starts off
with the three shiketsu students taking
Center Stage sagey declares that all for
one murdered his father who was of
course one of the guards at Tartarus who
died bravely while trying to prevent the
prison break he is the one that talked
to stain before he died and even though
seiji obviously wants revenge for what
happened to his father he vows not to
let his hatred for All For One blind him
and control his actions because if that
happened then he would be playing right
into the villain's hands for his part
inasa has been able to effectively
neutralize the threat posed by toga and
Sad Man's parade at least for the time
being he's been using his extremely
powerful wind Quirk to sweep both toga
and the Clones up into the air and of
course they can't do much damage while
being tossed around by inasa's
artificial tornadoes however we have to
remember that this is only a temporary
solution to the toga problem if anything
happens to inasa and he loses the
ability to use his Quirk Tolga will be
released and Sad Man's parade will
continue that said this is the time for
everyone to focus their attacks on all
for one and that is exactly what every
available hero and hero student does
they know that whatever happens here at
gunga will determine the outcome of the
entire War if all for one can be stopped
here long enough for his body to rewind
itself out of existence the war could be
over soon after that but if all for one
can reach shigaraki and reassert control
of his overpowered vessel then the
heroes will almost certainly lose the
war and Japan will be lost all for one
tries touching one of twice's clones as
it zooms through the air presumably to
steal twice as Quirk and use it for
himself but it doesn't work all for one
can only steal someone's Quirk if he
touches their body directly and touching
a clone doesn't do the trick the heroes
are are aware of this and that is why
initially only two of the strongest
Heroes were attacking over one directly
Endeavor and Hawks but now the situation
has changed Endeavor is currently
occupied trying to subdue a completely
berserk Dobby and the heroes are so
desperate to stop all for one from
reaching shigaraki that they are now
willing to attack him all at once all
for one thinks that this is an excellent
development it's a great opportunity for
him to steal some quirks and he proceeds
to unleash even more stolen quirks at
once in order to create a massive Super
Attack all the heroes and hero students
are working together to defend against
over one's attacks while also trying to
hit back at him at the same time but
even with toga neutralized all for one
isn't worried he believes that the only
hero who could possibly threaten him was
Endeavor and with him currently
preoccupied with Dobby All For One
Believes that he simply cannot lose
interestingly enough being overconfident
seems to be a major character flaw for
all for one you wouldn't necessarily
think that this would be the case
because he plans things so thoroughly
and he has like 10 backup plans for
every main plan so he doesn't seem like
the kind of guy who would underestimate
his opponents and yet at the moment he
appears to be doing exactly that unless
he's just talking smack in order to
manipulate the heroes into losing
confidence in themselves all for one
claims that what the heroes are doing
now isn't even bravery because most of
them have no idea who he really is they
are too young to remember his golden age
when he ruled all of Japan from the
shadows and everyone was afraid of him
these Heroes and hero students grew up
during the age of Peace created by
almight but that age is now over as Game
of Thrones would put it these heroes are
Knights Of Summer but winter is coming
Barina saw claps back at all for one he
he refuses to give into the fear that
all for one is projecting because
according to inasa Boiling blood will
always triumph over fear man inasa is
easily my favorite student outside of
class 1a he kind of reminds me of those
epic inspirational anime characters that
I absolutely love like coming up from
guren laga anyway at this point inasa
has created some sort of wind sphere
around all for one in order to prevent
him from leaving and all the other
heroes are sending their attacks into
that space in an attempt to destroy all
for one the villain realizes just how
powerful inasa's Quirk is and he decides
to steal it before taking off to find
shigaraki he launches those black
tendrils from the rivet stab Quirk at
the heroes and he manages to graze inasa
but inasa doesn't stop his attack and he
declares that his Quirk is even stronger
than usual because it's a windy day so
he refuses to let up now again though
all for one is not worried he knows that
none of the heroes can come close to him
out of fear that he will steal their
quirks so all they can do is Attack From
Afar that means that all for one can
just use rivet stab and other long-range
quirks to pick the heroes off one by one
and eventually he will win and they will
lose unless as it turns out the fact
that this chapter mentioned multiple
times that all for one needs to make
physical contact with someone's actual
body in order to steal their Quirk was
no coincidence just as the villain is
busy bragging about how no one would
dare come close to him a massive
menacing Shadow appears right behind him
and this Shadow dwarfs him in size all
for one feels something disturbing
behind him and he turns around quickly
and then sees tokoyami's Quirk Dark
Shadow at full power staring down at him
we see a cute little panel of tokoyami
as a child tucked into bed with a little
baby Dark Shadow and in the present the
giant dark shadow tells all for one that
even darkness comes in different shades
no one ever crowned over one the king of
the shadows and the Darkness he was
casting was only absorbed by dark shadow
and it will now come crashing down on
top of him we learned that as dark
clouds blocked out the sun on the
battlefield and as the Flames of the
forest fire created by Dobby settled
down Dark Shadow was able to grow in
strength and in size until it reached
its full potential Dark Shadow even had
Pixie bob secretly cover it up with dirt
earlier on so that it could gather as
much Darkness as possible in preparation
for this attack all of this was planned
ahead of time by tokoyami and Dark
Shadow the heroes knew that all for one
had to touch someone's body directly in
order to steal their Quirk and because
tokyami Square can extend far away from
his body they knew that tokoyami would
have the best chance chance of taking
all for one on head to head so tokoyami
started preparing as soon as the
shiketsu students arrived and now is his
time to shine or I guess the opposite of
shine now is his time to obscure anyway
tokuyami announces a new move called
Blackhawk Baldur as the giant dark
shadow collapses upon all for one and
seemingly crushes him into the ground on
that epic note this chapter comes to an
end and honestly I've been wondering
when we were actually going to see full
power Dark Shadow again and man what a
way to bring it back in an absolutely
clutch moment tokuyami's control over
his Quirk has come so freaking far since
the beginning of the story I remember
back during the forest training camp Arc
tolkiyami lost control of dark shadow
completely and it went berserk and even
though the Quirk was clearly incredibly
strong it was also really dangerous and
not just for tokyami's opponents but for
his allies as well things have changed a
lot since then in part because of
tokuyami's commitment and training and
in part because of the great mentorship
he received from Hawks and others fun
fact but in the next few days I'm going
to release a massive video explaining
all 20 quirks in class 1a including all
the new Quirk updates and upgrades as of
the final Arc of the story if you want
to check that out be sure to subscribe
and click that Bell so you will get
notified when the video drops personally
I think this was a great chapter that
made excellent use of the supporting
characters in order to show that they
are all contributing to the battle
against all for one Hawks tokoyami the
shiketsu students and even Pixie bob are
all playing an important role and that's
exactly the kind of teamwork I love to
see during a major battle but is it
possible for these guys to actually
defeat all for one right here and now
even with Dark Shadow at full power I
mean the story is heavily hinting that
the real shigaraki will be the final
villain and that old man all for one is
on his way out so there is a possibility
of him being defeated here but I don't
think so I do think he will be defeated
but I see it happening on the main
Battlefield where shigaraki and Deku are
currently located I do believe that all
for one will fail in his attempt to
regain control of shigaraki but it would
be pretty anticlimactic if he died or
Was Defeated right here and neither Deku
or shigaraki even got to see it happen
and that all those theories about all
for one being deku's father and the two
of them having a Darth Vader and Luke
moment at the end would go right out the
window and we know that would crush the
dreams of so many mha fan theorists who
are also Star Wars fans people like my
editor 414 anime shout out to him he's a
huge weeb and nerd and we love him my
guess is that all for one albeit a
weekend all for one will probably make
it back to shigaraki but once he gets
there he will fail to achieve his goal
of subjugating shigaraki to his will
that Battlefield is where he will
ultimately die in front of Deku and
shigaraki what do you guys think do you
agree with me that this is all for one's
ultimate fate let me know down below the
Epic evolution of tokuyami's Quirk does
offer us some interesting insight about
other quirks as well and this chapter
gave us some potential hints about the
true nature of one for all a few
chapters ago it was established that a
secret link connects the one for all
Quirk and the All For One Quirk probably
because one for all was literally
created by all for one so the connection
has always been there as a result the
one for all vestiges can actually sense
what is going on inside shigaraki it's
like the one for all Quirk factor is
somehow connected to the All For One
Quirk Factor this chapter also had a
moment where Hawks was reflecting on the
fact that one for all is a network of
power that links hearts together and
these links seem to go beyond the Quirk
itself because all of these Heroes and
hero students who are fighting together
and risking their lives together have
forged their own links and linked their
own hearts together so it is as if the
one for all Quirk has power beyond just
its users and former users it is as if
it has the power to bring people
together for a common cause yes it works
primarily through its actual users like
Deku but these users then seem to
influence the world in a very specific
way a way that brings people together in
a common struggle against the evil of
all for one and this makes me wonder in
what way will the inherent connection
between The Quirk factors of all for one
and one for all come into play during
the final battle what will happen with
the all-for-one Quirk Factor when the
villain over one tries to inserted into
shigaraki against his will in order to
reassert his control over his vessel
what if all for one isn't able to put
his Quirk factor into shigaraki so in a
desperate attempt to stay alive he tries
to insert it into Deku instead what
would happen if the Quirk factors of
both one for all and all for one found
themselves trapped within a single body
the body of Deku would Deku then be
subject to control by all for one or
would the vestiges fight him off would
deku's personality change would he gain
new dark Powers would this affect the
bonds that he has formed with the people
around him I'm almost certain that all
for one will fail in his attempt to
control shigaraki but it would be crazy
if in a desperate final move he tried to
control Deku instead it will be
especially crazy if the all-for-one
Quirk Factor ended up being extremely
compatible with deku's body because Deku
is actually all for one's secret son
there you go all for one daddy theorists
I threw you guys a bone the Darth Vader
all for one and Luke Deku Theory lives
do you guys think that all for one
placing his Quirk factor into Deku is
possible and what would happen if that
really took place would Deku stay the
same thanks to help from the vestiges
would he lose control of his body to all
for one or would he change it to some
sort of third personality a Persona with
new dark Powers which combines both all
for one and one for all and is no longer
even human a Persona with unlimited
quirks at his disposal a quirk God don't
forget to share your feedback down in
the comments below if you enjoy rmha
videos and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment it
helps me out a lot and if you still
haven't taken the time to subscribe to
the anime approach do me a big favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications subscribing might
seem like a small thing to you but it
helps me out a lot you can also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at
animeoproar as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys